Justin Jones 23 was charged with two
counts of misdemeanor assault and one
counter disorderly conduct after
authorities say he threw a cup of coffee
into an elevator striking Casada and rep
Deborah Moody a republican from
Covington Jones Vanderbilt student and
more than a dozen other protesters
assembled outside the house chamber on
Thursday to protest the bust of Nathan
Bedford Forest a confederate general so
this is 2019. he actually attacked
attacked members of the legislature and
then a few years later he's in it
so you know I wouldn't call throwing
coffee at someone like a caning or
anything like that but what I think
we're continually seeing with this with
the indictment of Donald Trump and where
everything is going is that the
bifurcation of American culture is now
within the confines of our state and
federal governments to the point where
you actually have a person who
physically attacked Republicans in
office I mean you'd think that would
have been news in the first place like
hey remember that guy who attacked the
the legislature he got elected he's here
now